chris middleton an all-star the past two
seasons
during the regular campaign average 20
points six rebounds
five assists nine-year man out of texas
a m let's go to steph with chris
middleton
thank you so much mark chris career high
for you
double digit rebounds nearly double
digit assists
what was it like for you out there on
the floor tonight against these hawks
it's tough um you know they're a great
team a lot of people didn't see them
being here um at this point in the
season but they're here for a reason
those guys over there are talented they
play well together and they defend well
also
what was the genesis of those runs we
saw you go on a big one to end the half
take your first lead
just staying with it um you know we
didn't play our best basketball seemed
like we were stopped with the ball
um they got in transition out in
transition it seemed like they hit every
shot
we just stuck with it kept trying to
grind them down and then eventually
going our run
speaking of hitting every shot you did a
little bit of that yourself
towards the end of the fourth quarter
were you doing something different were
your teammates setting more screens
help me out just finally got got them to
go i've been struggling some with the
ball going in the basket
um and finally they started dropping for
me at the right time so
you know i'm thankful for that
congratulations on the win thanks for
stopping